he should have been the glue in
relations between America and Britain
but through no fault of his own sir Kim
Derrick has become spectacularly unstuck
dislodged by an extraordinary leak and
even more extraordinary fit of
presidential peak the diplomatic corps
and its veterans are spitting with fury
I was really upset I mean really upset
and then I got very cross very angry
because I think it is a disgrace
that a combination a really terrible
leak and ridiculous vindictive comments
by the President of the United States
have forced him out of office he's
they've brought a good man down before
in Secretary Jeremy Hunt paid sick him
this tribute in this situation we had a
fine diplomat who was just doing what he
should have been doing giving a frank
assessment a personal assessment of the
political situation in the country that
he was posted and that's why I defended
him and I think we all should but listen
to how Sir Kim Derrick's civil service
boss describes how the Ambassador felt
in the last few days targeted in the
capital of our closest ally the pressure
on his family who have been living every
minute with him and he did not want to
put them through possibly months more
it was his judgment that for as long as
he remained in Washington he would be a
target and his family with him the
leaker is guilty of the worst breach of
trust in our service in my career the
damage after three days is evident in
the resignation of the most senior
British diplomat this afternoon sir
Simon tweeted this picture of foreign
office staff meeting in solidarity with
Sir Kim Derrick more people attending
this meeting than any other in his four
years in office the behavior of Donald
Trump has been unprecedented personally
attacking the man whose hand he shook
during last month's state visit as a
stupid pompous fool then it seems
instructing officials to freeze the
Ambassador out unheard off and enough to
render Sir Kim's job untenable former
American diplomats have also been
horrified
we work so hard in this relationship and
then the president does something that
is really counterproductive to the
relationship and you sort of scratch
your head and you think why is he doing
this does he not understand the
importance of this relationship and the
work that goes into it
and what needs to be done at the top
level to maintain it that much vaunted
special relationship is meant to be
based on a partnership of equals if
America's president can literally veto a
British ambassador so much for that now
Dominic where corn Sky News